welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
downer
[Music]
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer when you were young yeah they
didn't really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and know
how to use this
uh geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me but have
been so long they tried to talk to me
all the time all they hear is pika pika
you can hear him right you're adorable
they can't understand me kiss you no one
else here I don't need a Pokemon period
and what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
that brought us together and that magic
is called hope
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]